[MUSIC]
Oftentimes, leaders see themselves as the
role of the hero, or as the protagonist
of the story, and sees people that follow
them as bit players in the leader's play.
[MUSIC]
The Executive Program in Leadership
is a program designed to
give people a set of skills and knowledge
to increase their leadership ability.
To go from being emergent leaders,
moving more into a world
where they are leading big teams, whole
units, or perhaps whole organizations.
What we're trying to do in EPL,
it's help people understand that
everyone's the hero in their own story.
And the more that you understand that,
the more you can internalize that belief,
I think the better leader you can be.
>> I wanted to get a broader
perspective on leadership.
>> Throughout my life, I've been leading
by instinct, I felt it is about time
I add to my leadership skills in
a structured formal environment.
>> I wanted to attend for
my own personal development,
the betterment of our company,
and for the Stanford brand.
>> One thing that's unique about Stanford
is that focus on experiential learning.
Creating activities allow you to
experience the concepts that we're talking
about that more deeply
embeds the ideas into you so
that you can embody them when
you get back to the job.
>> One of the things that
the program has taught me is that by
better understanding my own leadership
style, I am going to be more aware
of how other people experience me and how
I can hep them to become better leaders.
>> The program is very good how to set
concrete steps towards achieving the goals
that you set for yourself.
>> The ability to lead change is
a big part of the EPL program.
How do you engineer change in
the organization, change in the culture,
what constitutes the culture?
Making decisions about what kind culture
is most useful for your organization.
To be an effective leader, you need to
both be able to understand yourself in
a deeper way, understand how other
people experience themselves.
And then all those things together will
allow you to create a story, to craft
a persona, it allows you to lead the team
of the organization more effectively.
>> There's so much that we are all
taking away from this experience.
>> For anybody who hasn't been here, you
need to be at Stanford for this program.
I'm going to go home a better person,
stronger, more vibrant and
dynamic than ever.
I'm going to go home to make sure I bring
a change that will help transform my
organization.
[MUSIC]